(coins clinking)
- [Mark] Hey, Jerry.
- How you doing?
- [Mark] You remember me?
- I can't see your face. Let me see.
I can get closer.
- [Mark] Can you see me?
- Not really. Can you see about this eye?
- [Mark] I know.
No, I photographed you.
- Oh, you photographed me now?
- [Mark] Remember I
photographed you a while back?
- Wait a minute.
Is you the one with the electric car?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- That took me to-
- [Mark] I took you to Culver City.
- I got you. I got you.
I really like, it was like that goon.
I ain't seen you in a while. How you been?
- [Mark] I'm good. How you been, man?
- Okay now.
You got your electric car
in Culver City. Studio!
- [Mark] Yeah.
- And you just restless.
- [Mark] That's right.
- Nah, I got you.
- [Mark] Yeah. I have
the prints on the wall.
- [Jerry] How'd your photo come out?
- [Mark] The photo turned out great.
The next time I see you, I'll show you.
(talking fades out)
- [Mark] Tell me your story.
You and I, we've talked several times now,
but I don't really know exactly
the full details of what
happened to you five years ago.
- Okay. I was sitting at a bus stop.
Going home from work one night.
- [Mark] Coming home from work.
- A couple months later,
I woke up in the hospital.
I thought I was dreaming.
The doctor told me that I was shot
in the side of THE head with a shotgun.
- [Jerry] You were shot
in the side of the head
with a shotgun.
- And he said the only reason I survived
because it was point blank range.
He said, if was not point blank range,
my head woulda been out in the streets.
- [Mark] And you'd be dead.
- I'd be dead, yeah.
- I can't see that good
out of this left eye.
My nose I cannot smell
or breathe out of at all.
- [Mark] Right.
- The skin here came off my leg.
- [Mark] Is there a skin
graft from your leg?
- My leg, and put it up here.
Roughly right here.
They screwed my head.
I don't know if you can see the spot here.
This about right here. Right here.
It's about right here.
Right here.
The sewed my skull back together
or something like that, man.
- [Mark] Let me touch it.
- Sure, go ahead.
- [Mark] It feels totally natural.
- It's only right in here.
It did something, man,
to the spot right there.
I wanna say they put screws
or something in there.
I don't know.
- [Mark] I wouldn't doubt
you got screws in there.
There's got to be more than a few.
- My front brain is gone.
They took my front brains out.
The doctor told me,
"Man, when you got to me,
I could see your brains
was hanging out your head
like they a snotty little kid."
- [Mark] Your brain was what?
- Hanging out my face.
- [Mark] Hanging out of your face.
- My front brains, yeah. He told me, yeah.
And they had to remove it.
- [Mark] They removed it?
- Yeah. See my brain in the front.
See the back brain is your main brain.
That's your back brain.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- That's what you think with,
move with, do all this with.
If I lose my back brain,
if I woulda survived,
I might've been in a wheelchair.
I figure, some guy in a
wheelchair use their tongue to-
- [Mark] Yeah. But you can walk and talk.
(talking fades out)
- [Mark] Before you'd
been shot, your life-
You were going to work, you know,
you had a nice apartment
somewhere, I assume.
- I had a plain apartment like,
a hotel apartment like, yeah.
I had to be able to see this.
I had to make airplane
parts at a machine shop.
- [Mark] Airplane parts at a machine shop.
- Yeah. Yeah. Called Duchess.
And this happened.
So I can tell you where I been,
but I can't tell you where I'm going.
You familiar with that, right?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- God is good though, man.
Dangerous, man.
- [Mark] So you're still in
a dangerous neighborhood.
- Yeah yeah yeah yeah.
- [Mark] On Skid Row. You're homeless.
- Yeah. Uh-huh.
- [Mark] Where are you sleeping?
- I sometimes sleep at
the Federal Court Building
on Hill and 1st Street.
- [Mark] Just like in the
corner of the building?
- Yeah yeah, the corner of the-
- [Mark] But basically on the street.
- Basically the street, but see,
you can't see it from the sidewalk.
They have security at
nighttime, but that's okay.
But I gotta get out of there
at six o'clock in the morning though.
- [Mark] So you got a good spot.
- Yeah. I got a good
spot. Down here the way.
- [Mark] So, I mean, are you frustrated
or bitter or angry about
what happened to you?
- I can't help it. So I accept it.
- [Mark] You were always this way
or you've come to accept that?
- I always been this way.
- [Mark] When you woke up months later
and you realize you're missing
the right side of your face and brain.
- And then I said, "Oh my goodness."
I'm gonna say something else.
I haven't looked at
myself in about two years.
I haven't looked in a
mirror so I could see myself
in over two years.
- [Mark] Yeah. How's your vision?
Can you see?
- I can kinda see this right here.
And I don't look at
myself in over two years.
(indistinct)
I said, "Well, things happen."
I just gotta accept that, you know?
And keep moving on.
- [Mark] Your attitude is amazing.
- Yeah. Have to, man.
I can't change it.
I can't stop living now.
- [Mark] You know, whenever
I hear somebody complainin'
about their tough life, I think about you.
- Yeah, I can't stop
livin'. I gotta live long.
Definitely.
God is good.
- [Mark] And help you out on the street?
- Sometimes, yeah.
People like you come around
and help me out a little bit yet. Yeah.
- [Mark] I'm sure, you get
some people who are scared-
- [Jerry] Now some is and some ain't.
Some kids like, they come and
talk to me and everything.
And some will cry. (shouts)
But some will walk up to me.
"Hi!" And talk to me. (laughs)
"How you doin'?"
"Okay."
"Bye!"
"Bye."
Some scared. Some not.
(indistinct)
You know?
Vice versa.
- [Mark] So they never
caught the guy that shot you?
- [Jerry] I don't think so. I don't know.
I don't know who did it.
I don't know who it was.
- [Mark] Did you see him coming?
- [Jerry] No, no.
The last thing I remember, I
was sitting at the bus stop.
And wham!
- [Mark] So you don't even
remember it happening?
- I don't remember it happening.
Next thing, I'm sitting at that bus stop.
That's all I know, I was at
the bus stop sittin' there.
And that was it.
And I was out of it, they said.
They said I had a 23 hour surgery.
- [Mark] 23 hour surgery.
- 23 hour surgery. 23 hour surgery.
- [Mark] They saved you.
- [Jerry] Yeah.
They said, "I saved you
in the hospital, man."
They were the top hospital in the nation
as far as head trauma.
- [Mark] I'm sorry. Say it again?
- [Jerry] They said, "Do
you know your hospital
is USC medical center?"
- [Mark] USC Medical Center.
- [Jerry] They said they one
of the top three hospitals
in the nation as far as head trauma.
- [Mark] Oh, is that right?
- [Jerry] What you said? Yeah.
- [Mark] For head traumas.
- [Jerry] For head
traumas, basically yeah.
- [Mark] You went to the right place.
- [Jerry] One guy say he seen me.
He said, "Man, I read about you."
He said, "They got you in the
medical miracle history book.
For surviving what happened to you."
He said me and this other lady.
You ever hear about that
lady that the chimpanzee
ripped her face off or
something like that?
- [Mark] Yeah, the monkey tore her-
- He said me and her
is in a miracle medical
mystery history book.
They make me survive what happened to us.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Yup.
Amazing.
- [Mark] So it kind of
derails your life a bit.
- See, well I don't know.
As soon as I get situated.
I get together and I go on the road.
Thing happen, you know?
- [Mark] Things happen.
They happened to you.
- And things happen unexpectedly.
So, I may have taken this negative
and turn it into something positive.
- [Mark] What words of
advice would you give people?
- Keep your trust in God.
That's the only advice I got.
Keep your trust in God.
Like the words say, "In God we trust."
He's the way, the light, the truth,
and the only, only way.
That's it.
- [Mark] If anybody could sell
me on that, man, you could.
- Yeah, keep your light, man. Hey.
They said, "There's
nothing new under the sun."
Nothing new under the
sun. What's happening-
- [Mark] I'm sorry. Say it again?
- Nothing new under the sun.
- [Mark] Nothing new under the sun.
- That's in the Bible.
See what's happening today happened BC.
You know what BC means?
- [Mark] Yeah.
Before the birth of Christ.
This been happening all since back then.
What's going on today,
was happening way back in the days.
Same thing.
The Bible said there is
nothing new under the sun.
They said-
It'll be weeks beyond years
will go by like months.
Months will go by like weeks.
And weeks will go by like days.
And you will not know
your summer or your winter
or spring or fall time.
You won't know which is which.
That's all in the Bible, man.
It's all in the Bible.
- [Mark] What would you look forward to
down the road for you?
- Happiness. (laughs)
Yeah. Happiness.
- [Mark] I mean, do you wake up happy?
You seem to be.
- Yeah. I have to. Have to.
Gotta keep it strong.
- [Mark] I've seen it multiple times now.
And every time I see you,
you seem in a great mood.
- Yeah, I been in a great mood.
I can't let this bring me down.
- [Mark] Does ever get you down?
Are there some days when you wake up
and you're like, "Goddammit."
- No, no, no, no, see. I have
all the excuse in the world.
- [Mark] I'm sorry. Say it again?
- I have all the excuse
in the world to see it,
to be down, everything like that.
You know what I'm saying? This here.
But I don't.
I don't use this as-
You know what I'm saying?
I don't use that and this.
No way.
I'm just blessed to be alive, man.
That's the thing. Advice
that made me so happy.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I can be dead, man.
- I can be dead. (laughs)
If I was dead, it's probably like I said.
- [Mark] Or it could have been worse.
- Alive, but in-
You ever see a wheelchair use their tongue
to get around and stuff like that?
I could barely feed myself
or anything like that.
A vegetable or something.
I haven't been that way.
But God kept me. Spared my life.
Which is great.
- [Mark] You're beautiful and amazing.
- Yup. This is great, man.
You guys are good, man.
You stay with me every day.
What time is it?
(Mark laughs)
- [Mark] Let's see.
It is 12:47.
- 12:47.
- [Mark] I'll take care of you.
You'll get a nice meal or two today.
(talking fades)